Hello world. It's the Raj and I've really
been digging smart contracts lately.
There are so powerful.
We're going to build a smart contract
that implements proof of existence.
It's an immutable digital notary that
proves the ownership and existence of any
document without needing to hire a lawyer.
The advent of bitcoin proved that we could
exchange value over the internet in a
way that didn't need to involve
a third party, namely a bank.
What made this possible was its use of
a data structure that distributes trust
across many nodes.
Instead of a few called the blockchain
think I'm ready to jump on the every no
downloads a copy of it and stores every
single transaction that's occurred in
the network.
It can't be hacked or tampered with
because it's secured by the proof of Work
Algorithm only Jeff Dean has that
much computing power. Since then,
several cryptocurrencies have popped up
adding their own features to the bitcoin
blockchain to extend its functionality,
but the cryptocurrency with the second
highest market cap in the world,
etherium is by far the most interesting
in terms of its potential to power a new
wave of applications. Etherium is
a digital currency like bitcoin,
but it's also got its own terrain,
complete programming language that
lets you build what are called smart
contracts. Let's rewind a
bit. In the bitcoin network,
any coins that you buy are
sent to a unique address.
No coins are actually
held at this address.
It just acts as a unique identifier like
a bank account number that allows the
total of the transactions to and
from this address to be calculated.
We can think of Bitcoin as a ledger that
records the deposits and withdrawals
from account. When we send a
transaction via the bitcoin network,
the old balance is reduced by some
amount and another accounts balance is
increased by this amount,
but no physical value is ever moved.
Etherium works slightly differently.
It stores the number of coins you own
at an address called a smart contract.
This is a piece of code which is
stored on the blockchain network.
It defines the conditions to which all
parties using the contract agree upon,
so if required conditions are met,
certain actions are executed,
no need for a judge or AWS or really
any third party to enforce the rules.
The ability to store info at these
addresses is called the etherium state,
whereas Bitcoin only stores transactions
that have been sent into blockchain,
any type of data can be stored in the
theory I'm state and thereby the etherium
blockchain.
The information that is stored could
range from the amount of ether you have to
the type of life insurance you own,
and since computation is scarce,
there must be a mechanism to limit
the resources used by each contract.
Every single operation that is
executed inside the EVM is actually
simultaneously executed by
every node in the network.
This is why gas gas is internal.
It can't be purchased.
It's used to calculate the price of a
transaction and ether and ultimately limit
the EVM and etherium transaction.
Contract code can trigger data reads and
writes do expensive computations like
using cryptographic primitives, making
calls to other contracts, et cetera.
Each of these operations have a cost
measured in gas and each gas unit consumed
by a transaction must be paid for an
ether based on a gas to either price which
changes dynamically.
This price is deducted from the ethereum
accounts sending the transaction.
Smart contracts enable etherium to operate
as a global server where you pay for
each transaction instead of a monthly
fee for some central server provider.
The gas as well motivates developers to
write efficient code so that it would
require less gas for the execution.
One interesting thing to note is that
smart contracts can't execute API call
directly.
If we wanted to build a weather app and
wanted to connect to a weather API to
retrieve data and show
the info accordingly,
that code would need to be
executed on each and every node,
so that call to the weather Api could
happen at different times as a nodes might
start executing the code,
not at the same time.
In one second we could have rainy weather
data returned and in another we could
have sunny weather nodes wouldn't be
able to reach consensus on the result of
this smart contract. In this case,
but we need data from the real world.
It's super useful. So the solution
is to use what's called an oracle.
Instead of the smart contract
calling an External Api,
the API itself pushes the
data to the blockchain,
so that means that all the nodes now
have the same data within the network.
So a contract triggers an event on
external app can listen to that event,
retrieve the data from the API and add
a transaction with the result to the
contract.
We can ensure the integrity of the
oracle bi using a smart contract as an
insurance policy against a corrupting
the integrity of the data. But wait,
bitcoin's got smart contract functionality
too with bitcoin smart contracts.
It's important to understand that each
transaction exists as a data structure
composed of inputs and outputs.
In order to send Bitcoin,
users must provide certain inputs,
meeting predetermined requirement's that
prove they own and therefore have the
authority to send bitcoins.
They claim to own.
Users can also create
contract transactions that
require a more complex set of
inputs in order to trigger
the release of bitcoins.
A simple example of more complex
inputs is a multisignature transaction,
which requires more than one entity
that sign off on the release of Bitcoin.
Proving useful in escrow situations where
two of three parties have to vouch for
a transfer.
Smart contracts in general are pretty
computationally expensive to execute,
so not every conditional transaction
is appropriate for execution via a,
we should only use them for features
that demand the distributed and secure
nature of a shared ledger.
I think about an apartment complex and
all the administrative work required to
maintain it.
If we use smart contracts where tendency
is registered on the blockchain,
they can be used to control access to
the building. When you pay the rent,
each tenant's access to
the building is renewed.
Owners with registered keys are granted
access to all the various types of
utilities like mailboxes
and washing machines.
We can also use biometrics
to help authenticate users.
No need to maintain a server.
It's all completely automated.
This can be applied to grant ownership
that is publicly verifiable over really
anything physical objects as well,
making them smart property and you
can even incorporate a company on the
blockchain and if we're really ambitious,
an entire nation could be defined not by
geography but by the rules and benefits
of citizenship on the blockchain.
Let's get to building to start
developing etherium apps.
We'll need a client to
connect to the network.
It will act as a window to the distributed
network and provide a view of the
blockchain where all the
EVM states are represented.
There are various compatible
clients for the protocol.
The most popular being guests a go
language implementation. However,
it's not the most developer friendly.
The best option I found is the test
RPC node, which we can install and run.
We can run test RPC in a new terminal
and leave it running while we develop.
Each time we run test RPC,
it will generate 10 new addresses with
simulated test funds for us to use.
This is not real money and we're safe
to try anything with no risk of losing
funds.
The most popular language for writing
smart contracts in ethereum is solidity,
so we'll be using that. We're also
using the truffle development framework,
which helps with smart contract creation,
compiling, deployment and testing.
We should be able to compile the example
contracts by running truffle compile.
Then to deploy the contracts
to the simulated network
using the test RPC node we
have running,
we need to run truffle migrate.
We'll be writing a simple proof
of existence. Smart contract.
The idea is to create a digital notary
that store's Hashes of documents as proof
of their existence. We can use truffle
create contracts to get started.
Then we'll open proof of existence.
That's Sol. In a text editor.
Contracts have state and functions.
It's important to distinguish two
kinds of functions that can appear in a
contract.
The first are read only functions,
functions that don't
perform any state changes.
They only read state perform computations
and return values and the other kind
are transactional functions.
Functions that perform a state
change in the contract or move funds.
Our code only stores one proof at
a time using the data type bytes.
32 which is the size of
a Sha two five six hash.
The transactional function notarize
allows one to store the hash of a document
in our smart contracts
state variable proof.
The variable is public and is the only
way I user of our contract has to verify
if a document has been notarized. Let's
deploy proof of existence to the network.
This time we'll have to edit the migration
file to make truffle deploy our new
contract. Now that our contract
is deployed, we can play with it.
As in we can send messages to it.
The function calls and read.
It's public state using the truffle
console. So what have we learned?
A smart contract is code that is stored
and run on a blockchain making it
trustless and immutable.
We can use them to verify ownership,
automate financial instruments and create
more autonomous software and etherium
is currently the most developed
platform to build smart contracts.
This week's coding challenge is to
create a smart contract that an AI can
interact with. More details are
in the read me get hub links.
Go in the comments and I'll give the top
two entries. A shout out next Friday.
Hope you liked the video, please
subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I've got to fight the power,
so thanks for watching.